In working out the answer to the last
quiz, we saw that when you're multiplying
2 polynomials together, we actually end
up using the distributive property a
couple of times, multiplying every term
in the first expression by every term in
the second expression. So we're taking
every possible combination of pairs of
terms, using one from the first expression
and one from the second expression. This
is actually a general rule that applies to
multiplying any pair of polynomials,
regardless of long it is. So we could use
this trick even if there were 10 terms
inside the first set of parentheses and 3
terms inside the second set of
parentheses, or any other number of terms
in either one. In any situation like this
we just need to go through one by one,
each of the terms inside the first set of
parentheses, and multiply them by the
terms over here. So in this case, we start
with x, and we say x times the first term
over here, which is x, so we have x times x.
And the second thing we do is multiply
x by the next term in the second set of
parentheses, x times -2. Then, since we've
exhausted all the terms inside the second
set of parentheses, we can move to the
next factor inside the first set of
parentheses, which is 5. 5 applies to the
first term in the second set of
parentheses, which is x, and then also to
the second term, which is -2. So stepping
one by one, through the terms inside the
first set of parentheses, and applying
them each to all of the terms inside the
second parentheses, before moving on to
the next term, in the first set of
parentheses, is a great way to make sure
that you have actually covered all of your
bases, and made all of the combinations of
pairs or terms that you can.